[Music]
hey hey everybody welcome back to the
whare in this episode I'll be working on
some colors and finishing the coaster
layouts and everything that I need to
finish around it in order to actually
get into the rest of the island now I
have to be very honest I actually found
it very difficult to get to actually
recording this episode and I was really
struggling to pretty much force myself
to build this stuff since its kind of
most the kind of drive that I would like
to have for projects and this is also
one of the reasons why I prefer smaller
projects over very large ones especially
after a couple of episodes I just kind
of start burning out of creative ideas
and if more or less becomes a time
consuming thing and something that takes
a lot of effort and time but doesn't so
much involve creativity or cool ideas
for me anymore and I feel like I might
be kind of heading into that direction
with forbearance
so from this point onward I'll also be
kind of taking a little bit of a
different path I was originally planning
to make a lot of things on this island
very unique and make it really in the
detail of the building but I feel like
that's focusing much more on making this
an impressive ride just based on the
amount of effort and time that went into
it and I'm not really interested in that
I actually still like the premise of the
rind of having a floating steampunk
castle but I think I want to go edit in
a much more modular kind of simple way
so a lot of the things that I'm building
at this point I hope to be using at
future episodes as well and just repeat
scattered throughout the island to build
the entire building up in a modular way
instead of making everything separately
and this is also the mindset that I went
into a lot of the towers that I'm making
in this episode with so I kind of built
them to be a bit more versatile than
what I have so far and definitely a lot
more like template then I can use
throughout the build so I'll be building
two towers I believe in this one and a
small gazebo and then going into
finishing the rest of the island and
definitely the two towers are things
that I might definitely just
repeat throughout the island used for
different kinds of areas I definitely do
want to make sure that it's not too
obvious that I'm repeating certain
things but just for the sake of saving
time and not making this a project that
I'm spending many hours just detailing
in because frankly I think that would be
a waste of time I'm going to do it this
way and hopefully get this thing out in
a few more episodes and have it all be
awesome and great and be able to spend
some time on other episodes as well
because yes I do have to admit I've been
starting too many series recently and
Favara is the one on my mind that I want
to finish the first as this was more or
less - supposed to be a side project and
a small idea
much like morose or planet coaster it
just turned out to be a lot more
demanding than I thought it was and it's
very different as well I I find it's a
fun challenge to try and make something
that's floating and try and make every
single thing on the build costume but I
think I underestimated how demanding and
could be before I went into it so that's
something that I just wanted to note and
it's also I guess a bit of an experiment
as to how you can work in the most
efficient way which I do have to say and
I don't think this is anything I've ever
talked about but I definitely like to
sprinkle some tips in there something
which I find is one of the most
important things is actually practicing
not just what to build or how to build
but also how to do so efficiently and in
a way that saves a lot of time I think
something that many people struggle with
and honestly this is myself included is
a way to not just build the buildings
that you want to go for but also be able
to build them as quickly as possible and
there are many ways that you can save
time like making your own custom window
pieces and repeating that throughout a
building or even making a part of the
building separately and then copy
pasting that to make an entire building
it does often require that I have an
idea of what you're going to build
before you start building it but there
are many ways in which you can save time
and I also think a lot of the best
projects that are often the most like
the most admired in a sense
also the kinds of projects were thought
went not just into what the final thing
would look like and how to build it but
also how to do so in an efficient manner
I think most of you will know alien city
and return to zero and if you don't you
should totally watch them especially
return to zero is a really great coaster
I'll put it down in the description but
one of the things which I like about it
is that it seems so impressive and on
such a grand scale when a lot of the
buildings are actually very in a very
smart way copied around to make to make
them look as if they're separate
buildings but actually there are sort of
variations on the same template or
they're just placed in a different way
or it's set up in such a way that it
isn't actually obvious that these things
are copied around and while to some that
might be a bit of a degree of laziness I
actually think it's much more admire of
all and somebody who just puts a lot of
time and effort into making something
because while I can definitely
appreciate time and effort anybody can
just put a lot of time and effort into
something and it's not necessarily
something that takes a vision or a
creative idea or a concept and this is
kind of why I'm a huge fan of people
being able to figure out smart ways to
build not just beautiful things but also
build them quickly and even though my
original idea with Favaro was to make
something truly unique and something
that looks different from every
perspective you're looking at it from I
think in this case I just don't want to
spend as much time as I have to spend on
this thing detailing it because there's
too many other things on my mind as well
YouTube series that are
and I'm also doing at the moment like
too many series too many collabs and
stuff so I don't know be stuck on Vivaro
too much and spending a lot of time in
this basically also as a very quick note
my voice might not be the best right now
I'm going into a cold which is kind of a
shame just because it means that my
voice can be pretty crappy for recording
so if I'm not using the force then my
voice is basically why I would usually
try to at least work around it a little
bit but I'm heading into a busy period
right now and I'm actually recording
this quite a bit ahead least more than I
normally would so I don't really see
much of a way around this
I hope it not too bad anyway I'm
building the second power over here
which is one tower that I do kind of
hope to use a little bit more in the
future it's pretty simple but in terms
of shape how it turned out I mean I am
definitely very happy with how it even
Chile became there was a lot of
experimentation with taking different
pieces though and seeing what they look
like
including the waffle piece which I still
believe is a great piece and I still
need to use something very constructive
someday but after I don't even know how
many tries of placing different objects
in there and not working out as the
actual roof that I was looking for I
figured oh well whatever I'm just going
to make my custom roof again which is
not very pretty friendly but it's
definitely the kind of shape that I'm
looking for here and this seems like a
nice color because it's very small and
versatile something that you can just
stick to the side of other things or use
on the sides of gates or users a lot of
things basically and this is something
that I do wanna do a little bit more in
the future so far I I also go into all
of my parks separately without any of
the blueprints or ideas from previous
parks but I definitely think that it's a
lot more efficient to save all of the
benches all of the lights and everything
that you're making as blueprints and
keep them with you and the same goes for
things like roofs things like custom
dormers pillars whatever it's something
that I'm not doing at the moment but
definitely something with which you can
save some time in
I would like to try that a bit more than
I currently do I also like the idea of
having unique objects for every build
but there's sort of a way in which
planet coaster allows you to make custom
content photon quotes within the game
itself then I do like and and that I'm
not really using as much as I possibly
could to make a bit more out of it TL DR
I guess blueprints are amazing and they
can save you a lot of time I'm actually
thinking about doing a planet to college
video about that it has been requested
but if you have any thoughts about it it
would be greatly appreciated if you
could share them because I'm still
looking for what people are looking for
in planet coaster college and what
people's thoughts are on the topics that
I might want to cover anyway that's a
completely different topic and I'm not
trying to suddenly promote myself here
mm-hmm
but um it's definitely something that I
was actually wondering now the thing
that I'm building here is the gazebo and
this was something which I kind of built
because it's a kind of a low open
decorative element on the island and
there were some spots in the island
where I wanted to have some sort of
building elements something to give it a
bit of a touch to it
but I didn't want to have a large tower
because that would block the view then I
have over there or there just isn't
enough space to make something larger so
I feel like a gazebo is actually a
pretty good way to go around that it
it's got a pretty small footprint it's
not too tall so you can fit it just
underneath what is going to be the coast
of [ __ ] so that should be more or
less fine and it's of course also a fun
way to mess around with a steampunk Ian
theme I do have to say though at first I
was considering building a gazebo out of
some of the ironwork ish gingerbread
pieces and while it's definitely
something that can work in a steampunk
theme it's not something that I felt I
got to work so well that I could put it
in the rest of the entire build because
even though you can definitely build
create iron work out of the gingerbread
pieces and it's actually my favorite
thing to do with them I didn't feel like
it fit in
much with the bill that I have so far so
instead I'm just taking the same old
kind of domed roof which I have in the
rest of the build to make sure that
actually fits with the towers a small
note though which I haven't talked about
but which you've probably noticed in
this video is I did change the color
scheme a little bit I'm still
experimenting with this but up until
this point the only colors that I had
were all just warm colors anything like
beige brown a lot of reds but nothing
else and while I did have a little bit
of blue at some point I didn't feel like
it really fit in at the time but in this
episode I really felt like it's
important to add a bit of Blues and
other colors outside of the color scheme
which I have right now so there's a bit
of blue green ish dark colors that I
added to some of the bottoms of pillars
the coast of supports and some other
decorations on the towers and a bit more
different colors in here and hopefully
that balances out the color scheme a
little bit and makes it look a bit less
boring because definitely steampunk is
very focused on the brassy colors but
having just brassy colors makes
everything look way too boring and bland
and I definitely agree that the color
scheme takes a bit more experimentation
but um at least I hope the addition of
some more polish colors should make it a
little bit better and a little bit more
like it has some diversity to it but
then again I'm actually still struggling
with this myself to be very honest
because it's quite hard to feature these
kinds of colors as very subtle elements
as there is small accents here and there
without making them too overbearing
because I still want to have the focus
on the more steampunk ish colors anyway
the dome is nearly finished at this
point and it's pretty much built in a
way as I did it in the planets Costa
College stone tutorial I think is lost
minutes I could maybe add some ironworks
decorations on for the thing but in the
general look of the dome they just ended
up looking a little bit awkward and it
was really fit in with the style so far
so I just decided to leave them out and
just leave the dome as
more of a simple thing there's a bit of
iron work on the top though because I
didn't want to have a cupola or anything
like that just a simple decoration has a
small peak on top of the dome should
more or less do so that's what I went
with and for the size of the dome
because we're both looking very empty
like that I figured I could put a small
dormer in which doesn't make that much
sense since this is a gazebo dome but I
figured in this case I wanted to go with
whatever fancy look I felt like going
with instead of realism per se now after
I finished the gazebo I wanted to get
into the coaster layout because this was
something on my to-do list for quite a
while since I obviously didn't want to
continue too much on the island without
finishing the coaster layout and
possibly giving myself very little space
to make this layout in because it's
already very crammed as you can see the
island is just a couple times bigger
than the station which is very small to
be fair and it goes over and underneath
itself quite a few times it actually
goes right all the time it's it's a
little bit like Nascar but shouldn't be
too much of an issue I hope but it's
very compact but I wanted to have as
much scenery interweaving within the
area as well and I also wanted to have
an exit path and a cue path which while
it's not necessarily going to be
functional could be functional if you
start connecting an actual path to it
and at least keeps up the idea that this
might somehow be a functional coaster so
there's not a lot of room to spare over
here and at the same time I wanted to
make sure that there is enough scenery
everywhere that it doesn't end up
feeling like a coaster [ __ ] and
instead you have steampunk scenery
beside the coaster the entire time and
that is basically the reason why it kind
of follows this very straight layouts
for many of the very complex parts of
the layout because it means that I'll be
able to play some walls in between these
parts have some decoration between the
tracks without having to worry too much
by the curves of the coaster going
through everything
and hopefully it should allow for a
couple of interesting things like on the
side of the station here and there
should be a nice facade with the coaster
passing by and the coaster station
inside of the building facade and on the
side with all of these straight tracks
next to each other next to the lift
level there should be some interesting
interplay between the wooden walls
breeches whatever is going to be placed
there and then for some of the curves
that go around the island they do a bit
of a similar thing to the first curve mm
air will be supported in midair and
basically kind of gives you this tour a
little bit further away from the rest of
the island anyway that's just about it
for today so thank you guys for watching
and I hope to see you guys in the next
video
[Music]